[Music]
howdy folks welcome back to another
episode of trendy versus traditional
where we make two versions of your
favorite classics i feel like trendy's
been on a tare of winning but you know
what i want to make the trendy dish
today are you sure about that no
today we're making
ramen and let me tell you i have made
traditional ramen a few times before
i've made a giant version of ramen
before too so why don't you go first
there's a lot happening i want to give
you the floor happy ramen good luck on
the trendy all right today
i am doing traditional ramen as somebody
who really enjoys ramen i know that
there's like a lot of different kinds of
ramen and obviously there are ramen
chefs who are incredible at this craft
so i am not going to be making like the
ultimate ramen today but i'm going to
make a home-style version that i
personally really enjoy the recipe is
from one of again
my favorite uh youtube channels ever
it's called cooking with dog so today i
am going to be basing my ramen off of
hers so i have some pork belly here
which i am going to now
slice up
all right everyone i'm going to ask that
all of you show me a lot of patience
today i got sick and tired of losing
cooking all these traditional dishes so
i wanted a shot at cooking the trendy
version of something the ramen i'm going
to attempt to make today is actually
inspired by a bring me video where
there's a ramen restaurant in tokyo that
makes a blue ramen i don't think i'm
ever going to achieve that sort of blue
ramen but it is going to be my
inspiration for today i dove deep into
the depths of the internet to try and
figure out how they get that ramen so
blue i didn't find anything but i was
poking around youtube and found someone
who made a very similar blue ramen and
that's what i'm going to be attempting
today but i've never really made ramen
from scratch with all the like key
components that really make a ramen a
lot of ingredients require a lot of time
so we better get started and i'm just
going to slice this in half so it can
cook better
beautiful i am also going to just cut a
small piece of ginger and we're going to
just
smash it
smashed
and then i'm also going to just cut my
scallions here i'm going to leave the
white parts for later whereas i'm going
to leave my green parts here so this is
the first step based off of some
research online these feel like two
major elements of a good dashi we have
dried shiitake mushrooms and kombu we're
going to add these right into our water
and these are just going to soak for a
super long time amazing stuff and our
kombu here going to let that soak now
i'm going to just
pop this in
gonna make sure it's golden brown on all
sides now and now we're going to
incorporate our secret weapon we have
butterfly pea flowers to my
understanding this is just like a blue
bomb that you were dropping into your
food that doesn't have any flavor i
don't know how that's possible but i'm
really excited to see this in action for
the first time oh
my god look at that it's so beautiful
i'm very curious what chris is up to
though
i don't know what he was thinking but
he's up for the challenge gonna sprinkle
in this handful here let's give it a
stir oh there's like a blue tint already
to the bowl i can see
it smells like how i hoped it would
smell it's very seaweedy it's very
mushroomy but the water is immediately
getting blue so i am going to now toss
in my crushed ginger
put my scallion in there and i'm going
to just add some water
it's a little dangerous in order to make
sure that it's submerged the entire time
you can actually place this bowl
right on top of here that is actually
part of the recipe i feel like to do
this justice you got to take a look for
yourself here
the kombu and the shiitake mushrooms are
already starting to hydrate so really
our next step here is to cover this and
let this mixture soak for like eight
hours be right back all right
i'm gonna turn it back down i have to
cook this for
two hours this is why chris i think was
like you should start first brb
[Music]
oh
thank you for bearing with me it's been
quite a long time i cannot wait to show
you this doshi look at this are you
kidding me it is
so blue it's honestly beautiful next
step is we're just going to add all of
this to a pot and simmer it for 30
minutes all right so i am back here with
my now cooled pork belly broth i am
going to heat this up again
so to this i'm going to add in
some soy sauce now
also some sake
we're not drinking on the job so
no i can't sorry i got a little too
excited
and then also we're going to add some
dark muscovado sugar which i
love using just for extra flavor
all right and then once that's reduced
i'm going to take that off the stovetop
and we're going to add in the pork belly
and let it sit there while i continue to
prep the rest of the stuff i think i'm
going to scoop most of the
soaked shiitake and kombu and butterfly
pea into the bowl first
then i'll gently pour this
sweet butterfly pea flower nectar which
is my wifi password please do not hack
me oh that's blue
oh that's blue
now that the dashi has soaked with all
of these flavors it needs to simmer for
a little bit so we're going to put it on
a medium heat for about 30 minutes be
right back first part of the broth is
done which is the pork belly broth the
other half of this is going to be dashi
stock and i use dashi stock a lot even
like sometimes you know when i'm making
like instant ramen good hack over here i
have some dried baby sardines and also i
have some kombu which is seaweed i have
combined them both together already they
actually have to soak for two hours now
i'm just waiting for it to
boil and then i'm going to take the
anchovies out we can cut to chris now
well our dashi has been going for about
30 minutes on like a low simmery heat
here we're gonna add a couple
ingredients to bring it all together we
have some mirror in here
we're gonna add that in we also have
about two tablespoons of some soy sauce
that's going in let's do one little
pinch of salt i want to be careful about
how much salt is going in here ten more
minutes please hang in there all right
so at this point i can also sort of
start scooping my anchovies out now
dashi stock is now done i can now go
back to my pork belly broth here we go
final step of our dashi let's turn the
heat off this is a big moment so we're
just gonna gently pour in this
holy blue
so now we're back to my now reduced pork
belly broth i'm going to put my pork
belly
right back in here and let it heat up a
little bit i think because the pork
belly dried up it's like a little
tougher now so i just want to soften it
again i can then slice it and then we
can do some searing once again coming in
with a little clean spoon no comments
about dirty spoons please still super
blue look at that
whoa that is
so intensely flavored for just that
little spoonful overall i'm extremely
happy with the way this dashi turned out
it tastes super complex i think it's
going to be great when we mix it in with
our our ramen onto some eggs i am going
to start prepping my toppings i'm going
to start by boiling some eggs here we're
going to do soft boiled eggs gently
one egg two eggs while that's going i'm
going to get working on my fish cake now
that our dashi is out of the way it's
time to focus on another critical
element of a lot of ramens and that is
that beautiful luscious velvety silky
soft-boiled egg also we're going to be
transforming these soft-boiled eggs into
a seasoned egg which is incorporated in
a lot of ramen first we just got to get
our eggs in a good place this is naruto
fish cake
most people are familiar with naruto the
anime i got this logo this little wind
logo so i'm just going to
slice it diagonally here fish cake is
essentially like fish ground into paste
i love this texture it has like this
kind of springy texture it doesn't taste
fishy if it's done right if it's done
wrong then
then get another bag so a couple little
hacks along the way here we've got our
water boiling off to the side i'm gonna
add a tablespoon or two of some white
vinegar it makes them easier to peel
we've got our vinegar water boiling
we're going to gently lower these in
first egg
goodbye second egg third egg going in
gently gently gently we're gonna go six
minutes so while these are boiling i'm
gonna get some ice remember those white
ends we had from earlier i am going to
basically cut them in half and do my
scallion toppings here i'm just going to
slice them thinly here
here we go our scallions are now ready
they're just thin strips last thing is
spinach but i'm going to wait for my
eggs here a wild bowl of ice appears
we're gonna make it ice water this is to
instantaneously stop the cooking of the
eggs when they're pulled out of the bath
pull out them boys
into the ice bath this is the scariest
part because peeling it feels like i'm
handling a bomb knock knock who's there
it's the egg boy while i'm waiting for
my eggs too i totally forgot about this
oh my gosh i'm gonna make my marinade
here for the
soft boiled eggs and super super simple
little equal parts of everything
there we go i was going to measure but
you know if it's traditional if you're
really good at this you don't even need
to measure it so i'm also going to add a
little bit of sugar
yeah
oh my gosh take a little bit out i'm
actually going to cook this off in the
microwave super quick too because it's
going to taste very much like alcohol
right now what a final moment this feels
so weird in my hand it's like gelatinous
oh it looks so good i want to cut it
okay let's do it let's do it let's do it
please give me that sweet sweet liquid
gold in the middle a gentle cut through
[Music]
almost punched my own overalls off of my
body
nailed it next step let me just make
sure my eggs are good here plop them in
this bath of ice cold water and let it
sit for a little bit while this is in
the ice bath here i'm just gonna go over
to the microwave
dump our smashed garlic in the pan let's
go our soy sauce in here our mirin in
here our cane sugar here sprinkling that
in you can't go wrong with some
beautiful ginger so we're going to toss
that in we're going to caramelize some
of this stuff in here then we're going
to add some water to make it more of a
marinade type situation popping back
from the microwave trip spinach here
just leafy spinach and i'm just going to
dunk it in here
you don't want to overcook it
oh
spinach so shrinks all right
hot just going to
soak these up let them dry a little bit
but i'm also just going to toss these in
to cook these real quick i have my fish
cakes over here and then we're adding
about a cup and a half of water
and this is where
our marinade kind of doubles triples
quadruples in size so now all we have to
do is let the sauce relax for a second
then we're gonna pour that sauce over
our eggs here and put them in a another
soak this is my first time marinating
eggs i love soft boiled eggs but i've
never taken the extra ramen step to
season and marinate them i can't really
summarize this cooking process more than
scared but excited that's an r b group
i'm in you gotta hear us live not too
bad it is pretty easy it's just very
cold here's my beautiful egg and we're
just going to pop her right in here let
her
soak that up
do the same thing with this one
now we just got to give him a little
savory shower here just want that sweet
sweet juice little delicate pour get all
the chunks out but these just need to
marinate uh for eight hours so once
again i will be
right back okay perfect
so i have my two eggs now let that soak
i just need to finish off my pork belly
give it a nice sear and then i think i'm
ready to plate it up
oh my god it's been another very long
amount of time look how nice and
marinated our eggs are feels like it's
soaked up a lot of that good flavor so
first let's prep some of our scallions
that are going to go on this kind of
long skinny pretty
strands of scallion my pork belly is now
cooled but i'm just going to really
gently pan fry these just want to slice
a nice
slice here okay you see that
not much color right now but i don't
want to cook them for too long though
because otherwise it would be too tough
just want to give it some color
all right doing a little flip look at
that
look at this
beautiful all right this is pretty much
done i am going to cook my noodles
really quick and we're going to go into
plating we've got our dried seaweed here
i'm just going to cut this into
big rectangles that will go on the side
since this ramen is going to cook so
fast
we have our our packet of this tonkatsu
broth so let's add this to our our ramen
bowl here where this is gonna land
as you can see i have my little ramen
station set up now noodles are gonna go
in now i'm just going to just break
these up as i put that in there make it
gently just loosen it up a little bit
these are my favorite kind of ramen
noodles i think they have the best chew
and i think they'll go very well with
this scoop out about a cup and a half of
our hot water
give that a stir ramen going in the
water move them around a little bit once
that's loosened up i'm going to combine
my
broths here and also add a little bit of
chicken seasoning chicken powder add a
little bit of that there like a little
boost of flavor if you will and then
right into this i'm going to add my pork
belly broth
i'm also adding in some dashi stock
please please
please have mercy going over to our bowl
of ramen
can you tell that i'm not good at making
ramen the broth is ready the noodles are
almost done look at them oh that bounce
beautiful scoop this out
so i'm just gonna plop this right in
here
all of it
nice
i believe it's like pulled up and then
kind of laid across
you kind of get your visual and then my
friend taught me this my friend a ramen
chef he does like a little two-fold
situation so going down
and folding it back over so it's almost
like a little fold of sorts like that
let's add in our seaweed
oh look at that beautiful spinach oh
he's sweating now the moment we've all
been waiting for our blue dashi
here comes the blue
now let's add our scallions and my egg
oh
oh
it is
jammy jammy egg going on there final
step let's go ahead and gently
cut through our
yolky egg here
oh he's shaking always shaking
i also have some bamboo shoots can't
forget about my pork and also a slice of
the fish cake naruto maki and we're
going to finish off with some scallions
at the very top
all right and then last but not least
the seaweed there she blows the egg
looks good the ramen looks good it is
bluer than all hell i think that's as
blue as we could have done it
let's see what inka's got on her side
there you have it a classic bowl of
ramen it looks very homey comforting
reminds me of the ones i had when i was
a kid and i
am excited i hope our judge likes it i
hope chris likes it proud okay i'm
excited
[Music]
three two
i shouldn't have left traditional i
combined a couple techniques but this
just looked like a masterpiece i am very
curious to know what it tastes like it
is time to bring in our judge who
happens to be my friend sakura she
is very well versed in the restaurant
industry especially with ramesh sakura
whenever you're ready
what is that
so initial thoughts uh i think angus
looks very traditional really appetizing
this one yeah why is it blue butterfly
pea flower is what's giving it its blue
tint
okay i'm gonna dig in
tastes like it should you know what it
tastes good it's not too salty
i think the noodles are cooked well i
think the most appetizing part of this
is definitely the eggs the eggs look
perfect it's a little on the soft side
you want it to be a little bit more hard
set that color though next step okay
there's a little bit more of a true than
i'm used to but it's charred beautifully
i
would probably do a thinner ramen for a
shoyu this egg is perfect see it doesn't
like it's not like dripping it has a
firmer troupe okay that's good i have to
choose one after this right all right
drum roll drum roll
i have to go with angus
a surprise not even up for debate blue's
a no blue's a no if i do close my eyes
it's a pretty good bowl of ramen and
angus yours was classic very inviting it
makes me think of home so we have smurfs
and home
home is always going to be smurfs well
thank you very much for lending your
expertise uh in our our ramen verdict
here thank you thank you both so much
i'm gonna take
this and it's fair i'll just i'll hang
on to this one thank you
chris i am a clean sweep
a clean sweep for season three i thought
i could switch things up i thought i
could flip the show on its head well
congratulations because thank you i
could hear and smell and see all the
stuff that was going into your
traditional ramen i knew it was over
from the second i smelled it but i had
to just take a swing with the blue thus
concludes season three of trendy versus
traditional thank you for watching keep
the comments coming let us know what we
can make in other episodes goodbye
you